my mindset changed at age 28 so before
that I was a different person four years
ago okay so you've got four years to try
out this mindset
and okay and go to Freestyle okay so and
you've been accumed you've been going
through saying things you've been
accumulating relationship kind of a way
okay where you were problematic
I don't think
he's still on my phone till this day so
I must not have been like oh no okay for
sex and like I don't think you realize
but hold on I'm not easy to have sex I'm
really really okay okay I didn't have
sex with you not not straight away no
did he did he ever have sex with you
yeah
okay this is how men who makes things
worship no okay no no no I'm telling you
girl this is how guys see it like I've
talked to so many dudes if they've had
sex with you once they're other girls
maybe he liked having sex with you okay
yeah cause my pussy's tight
thank you